[Applause]
the left's new wish modern lyrics for a
Lady Fish The Little Mermaid live-action
remake opens next month and among the
changes will be Progressive rewrites of
its classic songs
although the term made is still used for
female human sea monsters
the original was released in 1989 making
it 33 years old so as is tradition she's
being replaced by someone younger and
hotter or as Don Lemon says still in her
prime
[Laughter]
the film's composer says the iconic song
Kiss the Girl will be given new lyrics
cause in the original version Prince
Eric is encouraged to kiss Ariel without
verbally requesting her permission first
I'll remember consent is important the
next time I kiss something that I find
in the water
[Laughter]
in Poor Unfortunate Souls Ursula the sea
witch tells Ariel that gossiping and
blabbering about nonsense will annoy men
okay true but how is annoying men a bad
thing
you get it you get it if you don't I'm
sorry and the new filmmakers also say
the old song made girls feek they made
girls feel they shouldn't speak out of
turn so Disney changed a bunch of lines
and I'm shocked they missed this other
song from the original
[Music]
smoke PCP
disown family
but don't be a prepare that
sandwich and make some babies
you can sleep your way to the top lie
cheat steal and never stop or swallow
your pride commit suicide here under the
sea
[Music]
[Applause]
that was amazing
um yes oh my look like you were saying
you were so excited for The Little
Mermaid movie that you can't even
contain yourself oh my God yeah look my
my wonderful uh daughter
um she was young when Little Mermaid was
was out and so I know that movie pretty
well because we watched it endlessly
right and I could actually sing all the
lyrics which I mean if people wanted me
to I could uh but this this again goes
back to something I said earlier was
when you think the world is as stupid as
it can be right we clearly haven't hit
the bottom yet it reminds me of a couple
of years ago when I think it was a
couple of years ago remember there was a
controversy over
um Baby It's Cold Outside right at the
same time as uh what was climbing its
way to the top of the charts right that
song and you think really so I'm
definitely thinking right now actually
really yeah it's selected it's selective
outrage is what it is so Julie the part
where it's like oh it's not girls
shouldn't speak out of turn in the
mermaid song I actually get that a lot
from grandmas in my Facebook comments
about the show they're like cat
shouldn't speak until she's spoken to
it's like really because I don't I don't
remember asking you how you felt Bernice
that you just weighed in
I just don't understand what the big
deal is about this kiss the girl this
the lyrics go yes you want her look at
her you know you do possible she wants
you to yada yada kiss the girl which
sounds to me like the beginning of
foreplay like how do you even get to the
real thing if you don't actually try to
kiss her first and I mean I'm sure that
she would have clapped up well don't
answer that I'm sure that I'm sure that
he would have like you know respectfully
kissed her yeah I don't remember the you
know Buck I don't remember the part like
in the movie did I miss something I
wasn't that upset by it I also feel like
the movies I watched as a child Disney
movies some of them I was like okay
she's getting married to this Prince but
what does she want to do and I would
think about this stuff on my own and
have these conversations you don't need
to completely change the entire thing or
else no girl is gonna want to have a job
when she grows up but this is now the
the new routine right they've changed
Roald Dahl books they've changed uh Dr
Seuss like they're doing this all over
the place now and they're shifting it
around because they're taking a very
Soviet approach to this which is they
want to get to the youth as quickly as
they can and program them in a certain
way I would just say that you know as a
guy when you get a little bit older you
ask if you can kiss the girl you're
going to be kissing a lot if you're
girls you know it's generally not a not
a strong first date but would be like
excuse me about them I would like to
hold your hands and then I would let me
tell you I know and then I would like to
nuzzle I would like to nuzzle a little
bit and perhaps we could engage in some
you know it might not be questions it
might be your accent yeah I was gonna
say I was gonna say okay
Joe you're banned from movie theaters I
am yeah yeah ever since that incident
with Pee Wee Herman
it's a 30 year old reference 30 year old
wrestler
yeah
I have a feeling this movie's gonna be
really bad yeah we do we're hearing
about all these things that have nothing
to do with the quality of the movie
because people originally supposedly
were angry that it was a black mermaid
like oh not like in real life
this is not the problematic Disney movie
the problematic Disney movie is Snow
White okay because forget about consent
you have this woman uh she she's in a
coma in some sort of aquarium and you
have a prince riding to the woods and
he's like oh there's a woman in a glass
box surrounded by dwarfs I'm not sure if
she's dead we should make out so I can
find out yeah that's the problematic
movement really
I all I always kind of related to Snow
White because at a time in my life I
also lived in a frat house you did were
you in a glass block she was in that
glass box for a long time yeah she was
you know those dwarfs were coming home
after a couple of years and just like
throwing their keys in the mail on it
I don't even know how you cast for that
movie how would you do that you can't
even do that now you couldn't you
couldn't cast it at the CGI the dwarfs
yeah yeah yeah that's what I'm talking
about yeah just bring that up well I
should say I am available if anyone's
camping
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else